was there like ever a point in your life
that you have like internalized as like
a point where you're like oh this is bad
I should not do this thing again you
know when you were young or something
because oh yeah like you know every
parenting has like different like
disciplining methods and I will never
ever forget my dad's disciplining method
okay I'm about I'm about to call you out
Dad it's because I I might take notes
and I'm like uh I might I might actually
uh learn from you because I remember you
know
you know there's a lot of disciplinary
methods methods people have talked about
when they were a kid you know especially
in Asian countries you know you gotta
get a little slap you know a little
little spanking you know maybe maybe you
get shouted out or something my dad has
never raised his voice to me when I did
something wrong as a kid he never raised
his voice to me at all instead I
remember this one time uh I rarely have
seen my dad angry I can't even remember
what I did wrong right but I did
something wrong that's disappointed my
dad a lot and made it made him angry and
I remember instead of shouting at me
instead of like instead of like giving
me a smacking or whatever uh he would
just lecture me and teach me and refuse
to let me go anywhere aside from listen
to him lecture me and I swear to God
this lecture lasted around like two
hours
two three hours and I remember I did
this thing at like 11 p.m right I was
tired and he was like no you're not
allowed to go to sleep you need to
listen to me lecture you right
and he would just like in the calmest of
voices right not angry or anything he
would just lecture me but just refuse to
let me go anywhere until I had you know
fully listened to him and I and for some
reason uh like after that point I was
like I'm never angering that again I
would rather just get shouted up or
[ __ ] suspect for like five minutes
and then it's done my punishment is done
but now I know if I piss off Dad I'm
wasting three hours of my [ __ ] life
you're listening to a one-man podcast
for two hours
and I remember it was it was like we
went it was there was a point where I
realized I had shared trauma right
because I remember this one time in
Thailand I was my dad is like the eldest
sibling of this family right and he has
like a pretty big family uh and I was
hanging out with one of my uncles I was
hanging with one of my uncles and we
were just talking and I remember
um he was like one of the younger uh
younger younger brothers of his family
so I remember talking about oh you know
when when I was young my dad would
discipline Me by lecturing me for hours
and then I remember my uncle just shut
up for like two minutes and you could
just see like a wave of memories coming
back
yeah the ptsc just comes back and he's
just like yeah he did the same to me as
well
that's such a power but this isn't
miserable it was it was miserable but
yeah it [ __ ] worked because I I knew
I knew afterwards that that was the that
was the traumatic experience in my
childhood not not really traumatic but
that was that was like a core memory for
me just to be just to be like okay what
I did was wrong I'm not gonna do it
again I'm not gonna piss off that or
anything like that
um yeah so good on you Dad just uh I
might take that I might [ __ ] because
I definitely feel like yeah because my
my parents were kind of the same it's
like very rarely they would actually
like shout yeah because like I feel for
a kid and I don't know if it's just me
but like for a kid there is nothing more
I guess traumatizing than not seeing an
angry parent but seeing a disappointed
parent you know what I mean oh like an
angry parent is like it's like okay
they're angry they're scary but it's
usually for a short amount of time
anyway you can't be angry for hours
right you can't be shouting for hours
yeah but you can be disappointed for
days
sometimes weeks depending on the parent
and like that [ __ ] just lingers right
every hour that you're in the same house
as them and I feel like as a kid that
[ __ ] just hits you so much harder yeah
than seeing your parents actually be
like pissed off or like yeah or
something right so I feel it's like yeah
it's a very I mean that's a tactic my
parents used that [ __ ] worked on me as
well and I'm like you know what I might
use that man you know this the scary
part is the less they say you know if
something you've done something and then
they just say like one or two words and
then go away you're like
[Music]
[Music]
what is the line between traumatic
experience and learning experience right
some You could argue that's a very very
my favorite some people rule their
Empires on fear yeah my favorite thing
about that show though it's just like it
clearly like people didn't oh CL people
clearly don't look at that show and look
at like you know kind of the the the
depth I guess like parenting yeah and
look don't look at it as like the pillar
of parenting because it's just moments
where you know they could be like 14
year old kid is like uh Brandon you know
did drugs and you know stole an eraser
from a stationery shop or right and then
there's you know a huge [ __ ] dude
with like tats and neck tats and
everything just like shouting being like
you don't want to disappoint your mom
right and then it just costs to be like
uh Jose killed three people and I'm like
oh
this kid doesn't learn it I'm just like
you're gonna have to say that again
because you really have to think about
it I'm curious what the parents who are
watching this think of uh the punishment
the the yeah parents of trash days how
do you how do you uh how do you like
your parents
let's have three dudes who don't have
kids talk about parenting and how to do
good parenting that's always okay listen
I don't know how to do good parenting
but I don't know what not to do I
figured some stuff out yeah I know that
I'm not taking my kid to police station
I feel like their memory is just not
gonna be there it's not I do remember
anything from being six years old
I would if I was taken to the police
station that's I remember that yeah I
mean I don't know anything else I mean I
I remember a certain points very very
early on
um like I've talked this story before
but I remember like the first time I
lied which was uh I believe I was like
five or six years old because I was just
I remember I remember the feeling
yeah literally it was that it was that
yeah it was that it was literally like
yeah Invention of Lying moment yeah it
was literally I was like five six years
old and I'm gonna be like I'm gonna do a
Pro Gamer move I'm gonna do something
I'm going to do a devious move right now
what if I don't tell my mother the truth
and my mother of course immediately
caught onto it and I remember that
because I was like oh my first attempt
at lying was a failure so it was like
your mom's just like you [ __ ] knew
yeah yeah so by failing my first life
yeah it instilled in me for the longest
time that every lie is a failure I'm bad
alive being a kid your lies [ __ ] suck
like why why can we not just think
through [ __ ] for like two seconds okay
I'm having a trash taste moment I'm
having one of those things I can't
remember if I've told this story or not
okay right where I lied to my mom about
my hair no I cut it I don't think so you
haven't all right so you know
dumb why the [ __ ] did I do this so you
know when you you sleep right and you
wake up and you have bed hair and when
your hair's short right sometimes the
bed hair is like persistent yeah no
matter how much water you put on that
[ __ ] it won't go down yes yeah it will
just stay up yep yeah and so I had this
and I was like this is annoying the [ __ ]
out of me I look dumb as [ __ ] I must
have been like hey and so I had this
idea I was like it's not going down yeah
I gotta just cut this [ __ ]
like cut your bed here so I just had I
had a piece of bed head that was like
this and it just wouldn't go down after
I put a little water on it would stay up
and I'm like what the [ __ ] so I took a
pair of scissors run in the Moon
and then [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah I
realized that was when I realized
cutting hair not the move no I realized
I looked at the side I was like oh
this is the patch basically
because that's how Hair Works
and obviously
obviously my mom comes home and she
looks at it she's like what the [ __ ]
happened what did you do and I was like
um um um I closed the door on my hair
and it ripped it out
and she was like what and I was like
yeah she was like let's try it
here we go we go to the door we go to
the door it doesn't even fit like you
couldn't even if even if you by God had
willed this it couldn't happen based on
how the door was like free like it just
wasn't possible and she was like what
actually I was like I cut it because I I
it was sticking up and I couldn't get it
out she's like you're an idiot she
should immediately marched me over to
the barbarism was like just cut it all
off it looks [ __ ] stupid fix it sorry
it was super short there NAFTA because I
[ __ ] it up it was a dumb idiot yeah
because like I was a kid I was like man
parents are so good at uh telling when
you're lying you know and maybe I didn't
realize I was just a [ __ ] dumb kid no
I was I was bronze Rancor they were like
messed around
I was climbing still yeah I didn't know
how to lie yeah you tried to go on for
your old and they just have a
look at the subtle facial features to
tell if someone is lying did you did you
ever play your game boy late into the
night and then they would try and come
in your room yeah yeah of course of
course get really good at hiding it of
course my go-to was like I would I would
put it in the pillow but then obviously
they learned that I was like yeah you'd
keep you had to keep thinking of new
ways where you could hide it I put it in
my pants look that's smart see that's
yeah like stand up boy you're like what
is that what is a square shaped penis
uh I just [ __ ] myself
sure you're five years old that's not
what you're packing this badly but
packed like a USB did you ever did they
ever like to try and find it oh oh yeah
of course see I they didn't initially
but then they weren't convinced that I
wasn't sleeping yeah yeah and they were
like he's hiding it somewhere and they
would just maybe do like a [ __ ]
search in the middle of the night they
stand up we're gonna check the bed check
out of the mattress check everything I'm
like damn they're good she's good can't
figure this [ __ ] out did you ever have
like an experience of like going to like
one kid's house whose parenting was
obviously like very different and had
like different rules oh yeah and you
just like your mind would be blown by
holy [ __ ] oh yeah they could get away
with it the kid who like just had
everything yeah like Andrew just got all
the stuff he wanted yeah that [ __ ] was
like going to his house was like
Disneyland yeah it was like we had to
play Crash Bandicoot and Spyro now if we
the that kid in my life was like their
parents I guess their dad was just like
super chill yeah like especially I mean
not to say my parents like super strict
or anything but this these pairs are
like a little bit too chill yeah right
to the point where oh this kid's gonna
be like a problem child right because I
remember first time I went sleepover
right again this is around the time
where like I'm [ __ ] you know hiding
from my parents with this game yeah
right in the middle of the night and I
remember like dad comes in tucks Us in
is like yeah you guys you guys good you
got water and everything and then I
[ __ ] remember this moment where he
like as he's closing the door he turns
around he goes don't play Game Boy for
too long I'm just like what your dad
lets you play it
like any amount of time bro no no dude